leslie hey i just heard the news isn't
it great congratulations
thank you i'm so excited it's exciting
isn't it it is
yeah should i call a press conference
yeah call one definitely every now and
then we have these little gatherings
and leslie gets plastered one time i
convinced her to try to fax someone a
fruit roll-up
she one time made out with the water
delivery guy
in her office on halloween she was
dressed up as batman
not bad girl batman and i convinced her
to go stop a crime that was going on
outside
and it is my favorite thing in the world
you know what
america is awesome it's so full of hope
and small towns and big cities and real
people
and delicious beverages and hot guys
you just never know when opportunity is
gonna strike yeah you gotta be ready for
it yeah
are you excited definitely i'm fired up
yeah fire it up
i know they say that democracy or
whatever only works
when people get involved well i'm
getting involved so
i am gonna make a vow now that i will do
whatever it takes
to get this pit filled in even if it
takes
two months so sister soul sister
gonna get your phone sister tweet lady
[Laughter]
mama
i'm having such a nice time tonight i've
met many interesting people
and there's two bisexual guys here and i
got both of their phone numbers
[Music]
it's been like this for hours
congratulate us ron's got one just like
it on his penis
oh yeah what the hell happened to you
[Music]
well
you may now kiss the bride
it's been kind of a crazy night come
back
i think i need to return the sweater i
get
fused with my shirt in the dryer or
something yeah you think that's a
sweater shirt combo
i think it's going pretty well with dave
he wants me i can totally tell that he
wants me i'm right here
you know i'm here right
did you see my bra hmm beep boop
guess what i'm wearing the hot one
tomorrow the black one okay can i use
your bathroom
yes you impressed that i know what it's
called maybe i'd give you a lift home
oh good well in london they call them
elevators lift so you're gonna give me
an elevator home nothing okay let's
let's go okay okay let's go down to the
pub
that's right get a point we'll put our
knickers in the beetle records
this is an english accent you don't even
know one thing i didn't even say
what they can do she asked me the whole
thing and i'd even do it once
i'm like an elephant okay if i walk into
a room
it's like okay he's in there
turn this music down
tom's in the trunk jerry's on the roof
all right where to first
your mother's butt
[Laughter]
i'm so alone if even one of you thinks
about dry heaven in my car you're all
walking home
uh april's partying april party yeah hey
man how's it going
hey yeah hey yeah yeah come here
there's no reason not to love him but i
i didn't
[Music]
okay let's keep
and let's hear it for the boss
wow that was as long as it was loud
oh take me home dumpling it's betty time
ah hey ben you like star trek talk about
that for a little bit
they're making a sequel
i'm assuming with the same alternate
timeline but if jj abrams and company
expect us to believe that it's spock
with the romantic tension with the hura
and not kirk
well let's just say the message boards
are going nuts
i want to take you both home and bend
you
over and just
at the same time whew
i'm leaving let's do this we gotta get
her home
tom i know your business is failing but
this just isn't worth it
it's not about the business anymore man
she's a disaster we gotta make sure she
gets home safe
oh what the hell okay let's get her on
the bed
okay oh my god two
three
say what you will about joan but she
knows how to decorate a bedroom wow god
where the hell am i i just want to see
how selfie sheets at work
no come on let's go joe we left you some
water and asked him by the bed
hey okay how are you feeling how are you
feeling are you dizzy dizzy or are you
light-headed
when i look at my palm i see a lady's
mouth french kissing a dog is that
normal
well the pain medication i gave you is
pretty strong donna uses it for
menstrual cramps how many did you take
seven eight better wash them down with
plenty of fluids
no ron you cannot drink scotch with this
you're going to need to purge right now
okay
oh yeah no you're not wasting 20 years
yes can you open his mouth
leslie what open his mouth no open his
mouth
okay i'm not making myself throw oh ryan
we're on youtube
well good news is ron is resting
comfortably
everybody pants now pants pants buns
pants pants she's had enough
call it off that's not how it works
she's out wait i'm subbing in
april no that stuff will melt the shell
off a garden snail
whatever i'm puerto rican i can handle
it
oh my god okay this ends now
so
yeah hello again i'm ron swanson and i
am still
taking your calls hopefully about
tonight's gala
you're on the air hi uh what's wrong
with joan
she has a bad hangover which she is
pretending as
allergies is she gonna be okay wouldn't
know
never been hung over after i've had too
much whiskey i cook myself a large flank
steak pan-fried and salted butter i eat
that put on a pair of wet socks and go
to sleep
that works it does please call now if
you have questions about tonight's gala
or one of my other interests woodworking
uh novels about tall ships meat
that sort of thing my parents make me so
mad sometimes
just like the time they couldn't decide
who gets the dog so they just dropped
off the local synagogue i was like
oh say what
hold on ron hold that thought just for a
sec
hey honey hey uh it's your me
it's wife it's leslie uh nope
i have very big news for you oh well my
teeth are blue
blueberries are you having a stroke i
just ain't around that my dog's jewish
oh phone water ben
hello oh hello hi
leslie it's dead hello
you know leslie sounded weird i don't
want to wait for tom i want to walk home
i'll join you i'm always game for a
brisk walk
also if i leave you alone i'm pretty
sure you'll die
home is that way
watch out for that fence
you